-Well, guys, it seems
like there's so much
going on right now.
You got Prince William
and Kate Middleton,
they just launched
their own YouTube channel.
Cicadas...
[ Laughter ]
...are returning after 17 years.
[ Groaning ]
Yeah. Oh, they are.
Sunday is Mother's Day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I heard about
a woman who claims
to have found a cigarette
in her taco at Taco Bell.
There's a lot to go over,
so let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash.
[ Cheers and applause ]
First up, Prince William
and Kate Middleton
have launched
their own YouTube channel.
They plan to upload videos
though it's not clear how often.
They could post every day
or they could post...
once every 17 years.
That's right.
The cicadas are back.
Experts are expecting trillion
of these loud, obnoxious bug
to emerge from underground
just in time for...
Mother's Day.
[ Laughter ]
It's this weekend, so if
you haven't bought a gift,
you should get on that.
Though, Mom would be happy
with whatever you get her
as long as it isn't...
a taco with a cigarette inside
That's right, a woman says
she found a damn cigarette
in her Taco Bell meal.
That's disgusting.
To be honest,
I'd rather find a...
cicada.
They only pop up
once every 17 years,
so it's easy to forget
about them.
But it's okay, as long as
you don't forget about...
Mother's Day.
I mean, how could you?
Flowers, cards, chocolates -
Mother's Day stuff
is everywhere.
No matter where you turn,
you can't escape it.
It's kind of like...
the royal family.
Every TV show and movie
as about them,
and now they're taking ove
YouTube, too.
I can't wait to see their firs
prank video, when they...
put a cigarette
in someone's taco.
What a terrible meal.
It is the opposite
of what you'll get on...
Mother's Day,
and you get to eat it in bed
So, in conclusion,
this should be fun,
there's gonna be a ton,
Mom, you're number one,
think outside the bun.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This has been a "News Smash.
♪♪♪♪